[Music]
Matthew it's so wonderful to be here
with you today thank you for having me
it's super dope let's start right now by
you telling me what exactly your company
does so we build software for big buyers
of insurance to manage your insurance
workflows so picture a company like uber
Airbnb lift you need to run essentially
background checks on all your drivers
and all your hosts every time there's a
rental or a trip you need to have some
sort of insurance policy on one of those
and if there's ever an accident or a
claim filed you need somebody to manage
it for you and so we build the software
for companies like that to essentially
manage all of their insurance
[Music]
workflows how did you come up with this
idea so it goes back a number of years
my brother and I started a company out
of our dorm room that would essentially
let college students rent cars out from
one another and crazy enough out of our
dorm room we ended up launching it
September mber 1st 2018 it became a top
100 app on the App Store members on more
500 campuses in all 50 states it was
really funny cuz people thought it was
this big company and it was two kids out
of a dorm room and when Co shut down
college campuses it forced us to shut
down that business because it was in the
middle of global pandemic we took a
different route how did those initial
investors react then when you said hey
we're we're going to switch gears and do
this new company they were they were
super salty like there's no other way to
put it they're like we invested in a car
sharing up now you want to do something
with insurance and we told him like look
college campuses are closed there's
nothing we can do with this old app but
insurance is actually a bigger deal
right now than ever before because if
you think about it insurance is that one
cost you can't afford to
eliminate we actually before we ever
spoke to investors we went out and we
got contract signed and then once we had
about 23 letters of intent
we took that to investors and were're
like hey look people are willing to pay
us for this stripe for
insurance so talk to me now about the
the scale of your company how many
customers do you have how are sales
doing anything you can share with us
yeah so we started actually on this new
version of the business towards the end
of 2020 and then we went out to Market
with a real product in 2021 and that
first year
we were able to hit the million dollar
AR Mark and then in the past I'd say 16
months it's just gone Gang Busters we've
grown almost 45x in the last 15 months
will be the fastest Insurance startup to
hit a $100 million ARR we'll also hit
profitability next year so not only will
we be one of the fastest software
companies to hit that Revenue Mark but
we also be one of the only ones that
have done it in a super Capital
efficient way
what would you say is the most
challenging part of running your company
this was my first job my first real job
the only job I had before this was
selling women's shoes at Nordstrom for
like 2 months and then working on my
family's farm and so the hardest thing
for me was there's a bunch of articles
that tell you how to make your first
$10,000 or your first million dollar
nobody ever tells you what it's like to
go from a million in Revenue to $50
million in 15 months or anything like
that and so just having to navigate all
those different things on your own is
super tough and of course we have
investors and advisers but again they
haven't even gone through that and so
dealing with life changing so fast I'd
say that's probably like the toughest
stuff what's it been like to work with a
family member and how has like your
history shaped what you're building at
Lula I think one of the big things is
because we're twins we grew up so close
we have an unfair Advantage when I think
about other competitors like we go to
the gym together we we live in the same
apartment we drive to work every day on
the same and so one of the things that's
really cool is I never have to guess his
motives and a lot of times Founders
don't know if somebody's on the same
wavelength as them if somebody has the
same character if somebody has the same
ambition so while most companies are are
are fortunate they just have one Elite
founder I think we're we're in a really
good spot because we have two of
basically the same
person Founders your entrepreneurs
successful people the worst thing you
can ever tell them is you're lucky M and
to a certain extent I used to hate when
people St that but looking back on my
journey I'm the luckiest person in the
[Music]
world